front Court it is four players for three
starting spots yes we are going to start
with the captain
it is his third time as a captain
Giannis antetokounmpo of the Milwaukee
Bucks is your Eastern Conference
captain now the other two
I would not stopping We're not gonna
stop okay
make sure you can read Jason Tatum of
the Boston Celtics okay and Kevin Durant
of the Brooklyn Nets wow all right first
up Giannis antetokounmpo seventh time
All-Star he is now a captain for the
third time he was the All-Star MVP in
2021 he is fourth in the NBA in points
right now with 31 he is second in
rebounds he has eight 40-point games and
he also hit a career-high 55 earlier
this year against the Wizards Jason
Tatum
four straight All-Star games he's been
filling in as kdeve as a starter the
last two now he is a starter on his own
accord a career high in points a
career-high in rebounds a career high in
the CIS and Boston with the best record
in the NBA and unlike a lot of players
he's played 46 games this year no rest
for him and Kevin Durant
13-time All-Star didn't play in the last
two with injury but he was a captain for
both two-time All-Star game MVP
averaging nearly 30 points per game he's
also had 20 games with two or more
blocks 39 games for Kevin Durant and it
looks like we're nearing him returning
the big person we're missing here Joel
embiid of the Philadelphia 76ers well it
it was just unfortunate I mean all four
of those guys deserve to be starters but
you like you only have three positions
yep and Joel is playing as well as any
person in the game right now yeah but
it's just a numbers game but Joe is uh
so you're not mad at it yeah I'm mad at
that not I'm mad at that why are you mad
at me because I think five six years ago
they took the center out of the game and
the center should always be in the game
no matter what all this back court in
front of Joel embed as a sinner he
should be the starting center for the
Eastern Conference period all this two
and two front Court three back now and
ain't that the center is always been
it's always been two guards a small four
power four and a sinner the big man the
big man should be kept on that ballot
not not you know not these noodles so I
definitely have a problem he should be
well then then one of those guys would
not be on yeah so I I it's a tough one
yeah no sinner I'm not I'm not saying it
I'm not saying he is or is it I'm just
saying that
if you notice there is something that
those three have in common they've been
to the NBA finals or won the NBA Finals
so your popularity increases so people
vote when you get to the finals of it so
that should be the motivation that
should be not the motivation but another
motivational all right so read these
back to back you guys are splitting
these or is Kenny gonna yeah I'll do one
he doesn't okay can you lead us off
coming in at one guard for the Eastern
Conference
six foot two and a half I read the name
from the Brooklyn Nets Kyrie Irving
and from the Cleveland Cavaliers
Donovan Mitchell Donovan Mitchell Kyrie
Irving now an eight-time All-Star this
is his sixth as a starter he was the MVP
of the 2014 All-Star Game averaging
27-5-5 the last four games he's been
unconscious 36 and a half points eight
assists in shooting almost 50 percent
from three and the Brooklyn Nets are
currently fourth in the Eastern
Conference and Donovan Mitchell we know
very well about that 71-point game this
is his fourth All-Star this is his first
as a starter and of course first in the
Eastern Conference averaging a
career-high 28.3 points per game halves
right now fifth in the East Donovan
Mitchell 71 was the most since Kobe's 81
back in 2006 it is Kyrie it is Donovan
Mitchell Shack your thoughts of the East
as you look back at the roster that's
been assembled can't be mad at all great
all Dynamic players I'm most proud of
Donovan Metro up up here are probably
been the hardest one on him and I know
he doesn't understand this but I play
with a lot of dynamic arts and it's the
same way I made them better I talked to
them the same way so your welcome is
what you're saying no I'm not saying you
know great player with with or without
me but you know when you're a a person
and you're trying to motivate somebody
to get to the next level your style is
your style and my style is always
hard-nosing and you know tough so a lot
of people when when Chuck eye and Kenny
speak they don't understand we're coming
from a place of love and coming from a
place to get your game better so but
look playing great new start I'm proud
of him you know great job Donovan
yeah he
um is the one of your most unique
players in the game today
um because of his size I think he's
probably only six two
um or 6-3 at most
um but his physicality his ability to
get into the rim uh and probably the
biggest thing that's improved in the
last two years is his passing
and his three-point shot like his
three-point shot he could be in a
Three-Point Contest the way he shoots
the ball he Rivals guys who are known as
Marksman in terms of three-point so his
Improvement has been in those two areas
one yeah six one six one yeah yeah he's
yeah he's but he plays Above the Rim
system
I say six two I know I was like tall and
same size or tall yeah it's a six one
yeah Kyrie's played 36 games Donovan
Mitchell 41. yeah you know the that like
I said the only problem I had with um
zhan is he's missed 20 games that's a
lot out of 49. yeah that's a lot to miss
would you have gone sabonis
uh yes who was the who was the next
person in votes got to go with divorce I
don't have those stats
that's all the voters of popularity
contest that doesn't mean that that the
producers of TNT to him Adam left go
behind the camera you know what if I'm
gonna get bullied by anybody that's
these guys this is bully you
we're going to talk to HR